pourquoi avoir voulu écrire ce livre sur
Brad pit parce que c'est vrai que on
était étonné vous voir écrire sur un
livre sur Brad Pitt parce que je l'aime
ah ouais bah comme nous non mais voilà
si je trouve c'est un type
extraordinaire il est au cœur du cinéma
hollywoodien et puis les sur les marges
c'est à dire qu'il fait des films qui
veut faire et qui sont quelquefois
beaucoup plus difficile et puis il a un
caractère qui est très intéressant c'est
à dire qu'il est il peut avoir des tas
d'identité différente selon les rôles
parce que c'est un acteur génial mais il
est aussi très sympathique et secret en
fait on le connaît pas on le connaît pas
et d'ailleurs on ne trouve pas de livre
sur lui rien et on ne pouvait rien
depuis au moins 25 ans pourquoi parce
qu'il est très très secret il est très
secret parce qu'il est très pudique et à
mon avis très sensible donc en fait
c'est un homme
comme on les aime c'est à dire solide
courageux aventureux fiable et en même
temps un très très grand acteur ça fait
beaucoup de raisons également dans votre
lit
est-ce que vous l'avez vous l'avez vous
connaissez personnellement ou pas non je
ne connais pas c'est ça que tu connais
pas et je pense que c'est le même mieux
que je ne le connaisse pas en fait je le
connais puisque j'ai tout vu ce qu'on
peut voir j'ai vu tous les films j'ai vu
aussi des films publicitaires c'est très
intéressant le film publicitaire parce
que en une minute une minute et demi il
peut dire des choses à laquelle il tient
beaucoup et à travers un message
publicitaire qui a priori est loin de
lui et puis surtout aussi les films
publicitaires il les a fait surtout les
derniers avec des réalisateurs qu'il
aime notamment le fameux David Fincher
pour lequel il est allé au César c'est
un homme extraordinairement généreux
généreux et secrets moi j'aime ça
peut-être qu'il va peut-être lire le
livre il va peut-être apparaître là
alors
viens où es-tu pour l'instant on a eu
les coiffeuses de Cergy-Pontoise
ça peut arriver à tout moment ici
c'est vrai oui tiens regardez si lui
c'est brave Pitt
quand on parle de Brad Pitt on parle sur
toute sa beauté avant de parler de ses
talents d'acteurs c'est même deviner une
expression quand on parle d'un mail on
dit c'est Brad Pitt est-ce que ça
l'agace est-ce que ça l'a agacé ouais
c'est un problème pour lui alors il a su
s'en servir évidemment très longtemps
les premiers films il est quasiment tout
le temps torse nu donc et pour montrer
ça me plastique incroyable et ce charme
incroyable tellement Éloïse mais en même
temps tellement
il a su s'en servir en même temps ça la
casse parce que ça le réduit en fait et
en vérité il a raison parce que c'est un
acteur incroyable ça y est un truc qui
est intéressant c'est que c'est un très
grand producteur aussi il produit des
films que personne ne veut produire en
dehors de lui à Hollywood et notamment
le dernier film qu'il a produit c'est
blonde c'est-à-dire la ville Marilyn
Monroe réalisée par son pote Frédéric
qui est un
cinéaste génial fâché avec tout le monde
à Hollywood parce qu'il a un caractère
insupportable et donc il ne tourne que
quand Brad Pitt le fait tourner ils ont
fait deux films ensemble notamment le
fameux
L'assassinat de Jesse absolument génial
mais en vérité Frédéric il tourne pas il
tourne avec Brad et ensemble ils ont
fait ce film blonde qui est la ville
Marilyn Monroe qui passait sur Netflix
qui est absolument génial incroyable
vraiment un film incroyable et en même
temps quand on voit le film on se dit
que c'est un peu une autobiographie de
Brad c'est à dire que Marilyn Monroe
elle était la beauté charme la réussite
professionnelle incarnée et en même
temps elle était tellement malheureuse
que l'on est morte je dis pas que Brad
est aussi malheureux mais je veux dire
qu'il est aussi insatisfait de l'image
que l'on donne de lui très souvent
peut-être pas peut-être que je fais la
psychanalyse de bazar mais j'ai le
sentiment que je suis pas loin de la
vérité et je pense aussi quelque chose
qui est intéressant c'est le fait qu'ils
viennent beaucoup en Europe actuellement
il vient beaucoup en Europe
de venir au César soutenir son pote
quand même c'est incroyable alors vous
avez dit je ne le connais pas il ne me
connais pas mais peut-être s'arrêtera
t-il sur cette bouteille à la meilleure
en découvrant qu'il a un ami quelque
part en France qu'il aime l'admire et le
comprendre je suis en train d'écrire un
livre sur Kim Kardashian
je le pense je pense qu'il peut parce
que moi je suis sûr que ça peut alors la
France la culture française
qualité
c'est quand même très amusant ouais
Babylone c'est plus compliqué et en fait
j'ai le sentiment mais peut-être que je
me trompe et je crois pas c'est le
bouquin quand même un certain nombre de
pistes sur ce sujet j'ai le sentiment
qu'il est en train de chercher en Europe
un événement qui un peu comme quand purt
Lancaster a tourné le
guépardé parce que tout le monde a dit
mais c'est incroyable Visconti va
chercher Burt Lancaster qui faisait des
acrobations slip qui est joué les
cowboys et ça va jamais marcher non
seulement ça a marché d'une manière
incroyable but l'encaster sa carrière a
repris tout le monde s'est souvenu de
lui dans le départ ils ont même fait un
autre film construit ensuite ensemble et
en vérité je pense que il pourrait
trouver en Europe avec quelqu'un comme
sorentino par exemple il pourrait
trouver en Europe un metteur en scène
qui lui apporterait quelque chose de
plus j'en ai un autre exemple moi
c'était et ça concerne quelqu'un
d'équipe c'est que vous embêter pour
vous appeler pour louer la
[Rires]
isation qui se cherche avec les femmes
c'est assez bizarre parce que quand il
était avec gwynet Paltrow il lui
ressemblait beaucoup il avait adopté un
peu son look Jennifer Aniston pareil il
était un peu fou il avait un peu la même
coupe de cheveux qu'elle Gina jolie on a
l'impression qu'il a complètement a
adopté son mode de vie il a croisé
Daniel à une soirée il était acheté des
damarts il est chaud
qui se cherche au fond
bien sûr je le donnerai tout à l'heure
elle a tous les numéros malheureusement
[Rires]
oui la famille mais il a complètement
fusionné en fait avec le mode de vie de
Angelina Jolie finalement quand il a
adopté et les enfants etc on n'est pas
remis de cette rue vous dites
une des raisons pour lesquelles aussi
moi je l'aime et je trouve qu'il est
admirable c'est que Jennifer c'est un
serial on peut toutes les semaines il y
a un truc nouveau
elle emmène les enfants à l'école elle
fait ceci elle fait cela etc lui rien
n'est pas un mot sur leur séparation
il y a une dignité chez lui quand même
une sorte de pudeur qui moi me touche
beaucoup et je pense en plus que
vraiment il a il a profondément aimé et
il a il a vraiment espéré
quelle femme il a le plus aimé Jennifer
il faudrait lui demander en tout cas
c'est pas moi
je pense que Jennifer Aniston
et justement sur Jennifer Aniston vous
raconter qu'en fait c'est le fait de ne
pas avoir d'enfants avec elle il tente
inéluctablement ça conduit à la rupture
c'est ce qu'on a dit et elle s'est
beaucoup rebeller contre ça en disant
mais écoutez notre relation c'était pas
uniquement ça et c'est un peu me
diminuer dit-elle elle a raison que de
dire que je n'ai pas ça pas pu continuer
parce que je voulais pas d'enfant ce
n'est pas vrai dit-elle à ce moment-là
je pouvais pas en avoir et voilà mais
c'est rien de plus et on a j'ai plutôt
tendance contenu de tout ce que j'ai pu
lire sur elle et d'avoir vu j'ai plutôt
tendance à la croire est-ce que il est
dragueur Brad Pitt ou pas je crois pas
je crois qu'il a été draguer dans les
périodes intermédiaires dans les
périodes où il y a où il est seul
effectivement et fidèle
je pense qu'il est fidèle quand il est
avec la femme
[Rires]
toute seule quand même maintenant
on peut avoir toutes les femmes du monde
entier et puis et puis ne pas forcément
s'y intéresser
[Rires]
tout le monde court et son généralement
assez pudiques assez réservé et il vous
faut
de ma gueule
[Applaudissements]
Benjamin Castaldi puisqu'on parle de
fidélité
quand même qui part avec les gosses la
bagnole et l'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je l'ai trouvé froides mais je vais pas
non plus c'est pas parce que je l'ai vu
5 minutes que je peux faire un jugement
non dans la manière dont les choses se
passent et donc d'un côté il y a un
opéra qui se déroule et de l'autre il y
a le silence moi dans ces champs de
circonstance ce qui me touche le plus
c'est le silence et vous dites que Brad
Pitt vous le sentez dépressif et vous
dites entre dépressif on se reconnaît
qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire que Brad
Pitt il est il a quelque chose de
dépressif en lui alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il est très très
pudique donc il fait très peu de
confidences sur ses sentiments sauf
depuis trois ou quatre ans où il a donné
des interviews absolument remarquables à
des journaux qu'on n'est pas énormément
qui sont pas des
et où là il a aussi posé par des photos
et en posant pour des photos on a même
fait les films et des films sur les
séances de photos et des films sur ces
séances interviews et on s'aperçoit que
chaque fois il est
ici il se confie quoi il dit que il est
il traverse une période difficile ça
fait longtemps
c'est-à-dire je vais pas pleurer pour
lui je dis simplement que ça c'est
intéressant de penser que l'acteur le
plus célèbre au monde n'est pas un
simple produit lancé comme un gadget
justement j'ai une petite question
Guillaume tu es sur une île déserte il y
a Brad Pitt il y a une femme qui te
plaît pas du tout tu vas vers qui
c'est sûr bien sûr
vous dites que George Clooney est
tellement fan de Brad Pitt qui dit si
j'étais lesbienne en fait je avec un peu
compliqué il pourrait simplement
[Rires]
moi je pense que je la question la
réponse ou la connaît
c'est une femme qui me plaît pas
facile dans l'histoire aussi de sa
relation avec Jennifer et de George
Clooney c'est que une femme qui n'a rien
à voir avec le monde du spectacle et des
variétés il a posé une femme performante
extraordinairement d'avocat
international qui n'a pas besoin de lui
et donc ils sont à égalité ce qui
expliquerait peut-être en tout cas la
qualité de leur de leur relation tandis
qu'avant ils étaient pas forcément
égalité ils étaient en compétition dans
le même monde